[Music]
like a great of
s so small till you
[Music]
zoom
[Applause]
[Music]
High infinite
skin be the limit of a man limit of a
mind limit of a heart limit of a body
limit of the
limit of the sky oh the limit of the
limit of the human kind When I close my
eyes I see
[Music]
no
between
[Music]
you
and are you MERS you Meers you
m
between
and you been first
you first you first
[Music]
oh
my how could I be born
[Music]
with
we met long
[Music]
ago
just different and
forms beond the limit of a man limit of
a mind limit of a heart limit of a body
limit of the earth limit of the sky oh
the limit of the limit of the human kind
When I close my
eyes I see no
[Music]
between
you in the
universe you there you
there between
you and I you
first
you
you first
[Music]
you you
been
I skipped across the
water to fill my face and bring it back
to
[Music]
you I dug a little
deeper to find the stone they didn't
want me
to my
everything goes back to
dark I wish we could be
statu oh but they'll go
to time stops moving When We
Touch I wish we could be
statu over they go
to
IED one more
[Music]
picture to get the light just right on
your
[Music]
face
iot
[Music]
scripture to make sure you remembered as
a my
love everything goes back to D I wish we
could be
statues oh but they'll go
to
my time stops moving When We Touch I
wish we could be statu
oh but they'll go
to
my
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
say
love she
[Music]
need oh
we were
daning upon a fallen
tree just two
[Music]
kids know it better
be I remember
Ling lying through my tee
[Music]
[Applause]
sep all falling
leaves it's a
Rec only what
they inside my heart is a
fire it's burning like a
[Applause]
[Music]
thousand
I'm
running I'm
burning I'm
crushing I'm
[Music]
live I'm
trying I'm
lying I'm living
[Music]
for
myself even if
nobody's watching
[Music]
me even if
nobody hears a single
note even if
nobody is watching me
oh I'm singing it for my
myself for
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
o
[Music]
thank you so
much